Is a raw food diet good for cancer patients? I've seen several Instagram posts about this
We've talked about this a lot in the past and the number one rule is that
Be careful what you see on Instagram or Facebook
Especially when they're making blanket statements like every cancer patient should do this
Now there are some general rules of thumb that every cancer patient should
Start limiting their sugar intake because glucose is going to be a feeder of any cancer of any cell
But a raw food diet craze
Again, these things kind of go in trends, right? So the trend of a raw food diet for every cancer patient
Do you know I hear that from Chris speed cancer or something like that?
Well, Chris did Chris work did use a raw food diet for his colon cancer to my understanding I hope I'm not misquoting him
And it really helped him. I'm sure that's not the only thing he did
But he was also in his 20s when he had colon cancer understand a raw food diet even if you're juiced you still have it's still difficult to digest
So for instance if we have a patient with gut problems, let's say they don't have cancer at all
They come to us with serious gut problems a lot of food allergies and such
We put them on more of what's called a gaps diet a gaps diet as you start off with bone broth
I would not recommend that for cancer patients too high in glutamate
Then you go to soups
And you're at a very anti-inflammatory diet a diet that has food that is you know soft and easily digestible because it's broken down and
Those people with serious gut problems would probably never go on a raw food diet
They would stay away from raw food. It's too difficult to digest and may have too high a fiber content
Especially if they have SIBO to cause all sorts of other gut issues
So my answer to this is no absolutely not a raw food diet is not good for any cancer patient
Some cancer patients. Yes, but certainly anybody. It's over
40 years old, maybe it's you're gonna have much more time difficult time
Digesting a raw food diet. They already probably have a deficiency in in HCL in their stomach like we talked about in the previous question
We have a deficiency in in digestive enzymes your pancreas has already been taxed and you're trying to know what
Put that food in your gut that is going to be very difficult to digest
And could cause other things and if you have inflammation in the gut
Let's say if you have breast cancer and now you're doing something that's causing more inflammation in the gut. You're
You're you're making it much more difficult for your immune system to kill the breast cancer. So when
So that's
You don't you don't have to be careful. I mean those kind of things due to look at Instagram and say oh, that makes sense because that healed this person
So then you look at the comments and you got 50 people and said yeah, I healed myself with a raw food diet
You don't know their their age when they did that. You have no idea the rest of their history
You have no idea whether it's just the person who posted that video's friends who are making those comments
So they get more likes and what reviews on this they have no you have no idea how
Gidey those things help boost that Instagram post
And help that person financially you're just gonna be really really careful of that. That's why you ask these questions. So it's good